au marché de l'arquebusé gif et raise à
ses habitants le maire dos et a fait la
bise aux habitants appellent certaines
par leur prénom et a toujours un mot
pour chacun
normal dit ses détracteurs après 18 ans
de passer à la tête de la mairie
l'ancien maire socialiste brigue un
quatrième mandat
mais cette fois-ci l'édile s'est
affranchi des étiquettes politiques tout
en gardant le soutien des partis ce
n'est pas trahir les gens que de dire
trac je ne reconnais pas dans la
république aux arches
j'ai le soutien de la récup je ne
reconnais pas dans le parti socialiste
et j'ai aussi le soutien du parti
socialiste je n'ai de compte à rendre à
personne selon eux aux auxerrois et à la
vilaine belle et je suis dit souhaiter
décidé de partir sans étiquette
précisément à travers de rassemblement
comme je l'étais je crois jusqu'à
présent 22 ans temps forts débat
télévisé 26 sur son programme ses
affiches ou au local de campagne
aucune trace non plus de l'étiquette
politique de creissan marot c'est
pourtant bien le candidat ait l'air à
auxerre ce chef d'entreprise porte les
ambitions de la droite vocale mais veut
lui aussi s'affranchir ancien maire de
la commune voisine de saint georges sur
baulche il affirme ne pas être une fois
par défaut et encore moins celui de
guillaume laris c'est parce que le 10 à
0 aujourd'hui ils me disent plutôt que
je suis soutenue par les députés ont ce
qui est plutôt positif
et pour ceux qui me connaissent en
général ils savent très bien que quand
je fais quelque chose c'est que j'ai
envie de le faire et c'est pas parce
qu'on m'a obligé à faire cette députée
de la circonscription c'est le député de
la ville d'auxerre donc les gens soient
soucieux du travail du député est plutôt
positif d'abord unis les verts vont au
final présenté deux listes à auxerre les
électeurs auront le choix entre deux
femmes qui se revendiquent l'une comme
l'autre écologistes oui donc c'est
quelque part oui l'écologie
maud navarre et l'une d'elles est la
jeune femme ne regrette en rien cette
situation cette journaliste de
profession ne craignent ni de bruit et
le message nous de perdre des électeurs
sûre d'elle et de ses forces l'ancienne
adjointe de guy férez se déclare comme
l'unique candidat alors il ya qu une
seule liste qui est soutenu par europe
ecologie les verts et c'est la mienne
voilà c'est la seule liste écologiste
officielle et donc nous sommes les
écologistes la seule liste écologiste
c'est celle qui propose un vrai
renouvellement c'est la mienne qui peut
apporter justement des personnes
nouvelles avec une tête de liste comme
moi c'est dans le même quartier que
florence l'orif est elle aussi comme pas
lieu ce jour-là professeur de sport dans
le civil elle forme un binôme avec denis
roycourt un autre ancien adjoint de guy
fait leur liste veut défendre une
écologie plus sociale et citoyenne plus
à gauche selon lui mais la candidate des
plans la confusion créée chez les verts
nous regrettons sa dissidence en fait il
ya une deuxième liste parce que madame
navarre a claqué la porte de nos
troupeaux en cours de campagne et elle a
souhaité solliciter l'appui de europe
ecologie les verts etc le bureau
régional de dijon qui l'a nommée tête de
liste sans obtenir compte deux des
militants de terrain
autre inconnue de ce scrutin est le
score du rassemblement national aux
dernières municipales l'extrême droite a
frôlé le second tour son candidat pascal
roy a pour lui a décliné toute
sollicitation des médias et a refusé de
répondre à nos questions